a hacking attack on a water treatment
plant is raising big questions about the
vulnerability
of critical facilities nationwide
federal investigators are searching for
a hacker who tried to poison the oldsmar
florida water system on friday just 15
miles from the super bowl right before
the big game
officials say the intruder broke into
the water treatment controls for about
five minutes
as jeff begues reports the intent was to
add too much of a dangerous chemical
this is obviously a significant and
potentially dangerous increase
pinellas county sheriff bob gaultieri
says a water treatment plant operator
first noticed the remote access hack
the bad actor increased the amount of
sodium hydroxide or
lie in the water supply from 100 parts
per million to more than 11 thousand
the public was never in danger it would
have taken between 24 and 36 hours for
that water to hit the water supply
system
for the 15 thousand residents of oldsmar
florida
the increase of sodium hydroxide in the
water supply could have caused vomiting
chest and abdominal pain this type of
activity
in this type of hacking of critical
infrastructure
is not necessarily limited to just water
supply systems it can be
anything and that's of concern to people
like robert lee
ceo of cyber security firm dragos
he says this hack wasn't necessarily
sophisticated
but many smaller cities like oldsmar
don't always have the resources to
protect
against them we think about some of our
most critical infrastructures
they're pretty well protected when you
think about a municipality or some of
our smaller
infrastructure they don't get the same
resources as the others
lee says on the local level communities
need to invest in stronger cyber
security
and dedicated staffing to protect
against tax
when it comes to our smaller
infrastructure sites they are much more
vulnerable
in the sense that they aren't investing
as much as security but they're also not
necessarily as big of a target on a
national scale that may not seem
impactful but to those 15 000 people and
their families that's extraordinarily
impactful
the secret service cyber units are
working in this case they are leading
the investigation along with help from
the fbi
trying to track down the suspect or
suspects behind this hack and trying to
determine whether they are
here in the u.s or somewhere overseas
it's the kind of investigation that
could take
months or longer anthony such a close
call jeff
thank you